win the american revolution in the war
that won it thanks so much thank you
tonight we're honored to have as our
guest douglas waller here to discuss his
new book disciples the world war ii
missions of the cia directors who fought
for wild bill donovan published by simon
schuster
waller is a veteran magazine
correspondent arthur and lecturer as
correspondent for newsweek and time he
covered the pentagon congress the state
department the white house and the cia
his previous books include wow bill
donovan
a question of loyalty a biography of
general billy mitchell big red about a
tragic nuclear
submarine
air warriors
about navy pilots and commandos the
story of america's secret soldiers
publishers weekly calls disciples
meticulously researched kirkus review
says
waller keeps the interest high and the
page is turning in one of the more
interesting spy books of the year please
welcome douglas waller
well thanks ellen it's it's good to be
back at quail ridge i spoke here about
three years ago on the wild bill donovan
biography and we moved
down to raleigh north carolina from
washington dc three years ago so this is
my home now and quail ridge is my
neighborhood bookstore
and you really should feel lucky that
you have a bookstore like quail ridge
here this is
independent bookstores like quail ridge
are really national treasures that we
all should cherish
so let's talk about uh disciples
after i published my biography of
general william wild bill donovan
four years ago
i had a tough time figuring out what to
do next
donovan was really larger than life
a world war one hero who had been
awarded the medal of honor a millionaire
republican wall street lawyer often
mentioned as a presidential uh contender
and the man franklin roosevelt picked to
be his top spy chief during world war ii
in july 1941 just by way of background
donovan began what eventually became
known as the office of strategic
services the oss
he started the spy agent really with
only just one guy and that was himself
but over the course of the war he built
up a force of more than ten thousand
spies saboteurs commandos research
analysts propagandists and r and uh
support personnel in stations all over
the world
while bill he got that nickname uh in
world war ii i mean world war one
leading infantry men was also a
controversial character his agents
revered him his political enemies and he
had a lot of them in washington thought
he was as big a threat to america as
adolf hitler was
so donovan was going to be a hard act to
follow i finally settled on four
subjects for my next book
these four were among the most
controversial directors this uh central
intelligence agency has ever had
alan dulles richard helms
william colby and william casey
allen dulles who was america's spy chief
from 1953 to 61 led the calamitous
operation to land cia-trained
anti-castro guerrillas at cuba's bay of
pigs
richard helms a cia director from 1966
to 73 was convicted of lying to congress
over the cia's effort to oust president
salvador allende of chile
bill colby who was director
from 1973 to 76 became a pariah among
the agencies old hands for releasing to
congress what became known as the family
jewels report of cia misdeeds during the
1950s and early 70s
bill casey who was cia director from
1981 to 87 nearly brought down the
agency in ronald reagan's presidency
from the scheme that secretly supplied
nicaragua's contras with money raked off
from the sale of arms to iran for
american hostages in beirut this was the
iran contra scandals
but before these men became their
nation's top spy master they served
under donovan as operatives disciples is
about the secret war they fought in the
office of strategic services which is a
precursor to the today's cia
these four men i quickly found out were
characters as rich and complex and
multifaceted as donovan was
alan dulles looked like the headmaster
of an upper-class english boarding
school
he was dressed usually in a bow tie and
a tweed jacket his wiry hair was always
slightly mussed
his mustache was always neatly trimmed
and he almost always had a pipe clenched
in his teeth
he had sparkling gray blue eyes
and a soft voice that invited people to
pour their hearts out to him
dulles secret nature however could be
absolutely maddening one of his agents
once joked that if you asked him if it
was raining outside he'd laugh at you
and he wouldn't tell you
occasionally it was a hearty laugh when
he was really amused about something
most of the time it was kind of a
mirthless ho ho ho
that he turned on when he was trying to
ingratiate himself with a stranger or
trying to deflect deflect a question he
didn't want to answer
that country gentleman routine though
also masked a fierce competitor not
willing to give up a single point on the
tennis court a back alley fighter is one
of his agents called him and a devious
man who sized up people based really on
whether they could be useful to him
richard helms our second guy was a cul
was the consummate uh spy he had a mona
lisa-like smile his hair was always
slicked back uh neatly and he had a cold
personality
he didn't make friends easily and with
the friends he had he never let his
guard down with him you can find plenty
of stories uh in the cia about its
colorful characters and they had an
awful lot of them
but no one could think of an anecdote
about helms
the consummate intelligence officer he
left no trail behind
people had to come up uh had to strain
to come up with something to say about
him because he left so little impression
on him
at parties he was a good dancer a
charming conversationalist but he rarely
drank more than one martini that each
night so his head would stay clear and
he usually was the first to leave early
so he'd be fresh at the office the next
day
or
if the party was at his house he would
shoe away the guest when his bedtime
neared
now he smoked two packs of chesterfield
a day for most of his life he was
immaculately tailored his shoes were
specially made for a small high arched
feet
at seven hundred dollars a pair from
peel and company in london
and he wore his belt with a buckle on
the side instead of the front which i
thought was kind of odd i don't know why
colby
our third our third guy was once asked
the definite his definition of the
perfect spy
he gave a pretty obvious answer answer
the one you don't see
kobe looked like a man who could be
overlooked he was slightly built he had
pale dull eyes behind horned rim glasses
and his hair was always neatly parted on
the side
a private man he was unfailingly
polite with very refined manners
he paid no attention to what he wore he
repaired plumbing and did carpentry work
around the house but he had his guilty
pleasures
he enjoyed a good bottle of sauvignon
blanc
on weekends he drove a red fiat uh
sports car and he appreciated beautiful
women although i could find no evidence
that he ever acted on what he noticed
classical greek and roman uh heroes
intrigued colby one of his favorite
movies was lawrence of arabia you
remember peter o'toole played
t.h lawrence that was colby's hero
colby once told a family member that he
never had a nightmare never even dreamed
for that matter which i thought was kind
of unusual in the oss and later the cia
colleagues recall
bill colby as a soldier priest but a
loner they never really knew
an informal poll was once circulated
among nearly 60 retired cia officers
with just two questions
number one
if you were shipwrecked on a pleasant
deserted island with plenty of food and
liquor and every hope a ship would pass
by to pick you up who would you choose
to be with
well dulles won handily over colby
because everybody thought he would be
far better company on the island
second question
if you were stuck on a miserable
deserted island with little food or hope
or surviv of survival and you
desperately wanted to escape who would
you choose to be with
bill colby easily led dulles because as
one of the respondents said he would
know how to build a boat to get you off
the island
and he would build the boat big enough
for two
bill casey always made a bad first
impression
on others even more so when he was
middle aged he was tall and lumpy he had
a jowly face thick eyes
thick lips bulging eyes and wisp of
white hair on his balding head
he wore expensive suits always rumpled
his tie often stained with what he'd
eaten for lunch and he frequently
mumbled as if he had marbles stuffed in
his mouth
his acquaintances
he made usually ended up being either
lifelong friends who worshiped him or
skeptics who just couldn't escape the
uneasy feeling that he was some kind of
devious operator
but looks were deceiving with casey
that slovenly appearance covered a body
constantly on the go he once wrote a
lengthy article on how to quickly
consume a non-fiction book
casey would read from back to front
he'd start with the index
and the source notes to pick out what he
needed thought he needed to know and
then he'd bypass the rest
i've always thought i'd hate for him to
read one of my books that way
he had a photographic memory he could
retain passages almost verbatim from
reports or journal articles that he just
seemed to be flipping through he had an
insatiably curious mind on family
vacations in europe casey's idea of fun
was scooping up the timetable brochures
at train stations and then studying them
in his hotel room overnight
so he could recite from memory the
itineraries the next morning
sounds like a lot of fun
for all the differences of these four
guys i found a common thread that ran
between alan dulles richard helms bill
casey and bill colby
they were all smart
in fact i think you can call them
intellectuals
because they were voracious readers they
were thoughtful and they were creatures
of reason
but these weren't the ivory tower
type of guys
who would sit around for hours in
doubtful uh introspection
they these were strong decisive and
supremely confident men of action they
were doers who believed they could shape
history rather than letting it control
them so what did they do in world war
two
let's start with dulles
he was born in 1893 with a club foot
surgeons rep repaired it but the family
always treated this as some kind of deep
dark secret
his father was a liberal presbyterian
minister his mother came from diplomatic
nobility
allen's grandfather uh and his uncle on
his mother's side were secretaries of
state
dulles was a precocious child when he
was eight years old he wrote a book on
the second boer war
now
it was only 31 pages long had a lot of
spelling mistakes in it but his
grandfather published 700 copies
of it and he got a good review in the
washington post
from it he went to princeton played
around a lot until his senior year and
then he finally buckled down in 1916 he
joined the state department and during
world war one
uh he was stationed with the american
legation in burns switzerland
by default he became the legations
intelligence officer there just wasn't
anybody else around for the job
and neutral switzerland was an espionage
haven uh for the warring powers at that
time
dulles basically taught himself how to
be a spy he learned some hard lessons on
the job
late one afternoon for example a man
with a thick russian accent
phoned the legation and insisted on
talking to an american diplomat
dulles was late for a tennis state
he had he told the man to come back the
next morning when the uh legation opened
and he hung up
he found out later that the russian was
vladimir lenin
who was headed back to his homeland the
next morning dulles would tell that
anecdote time and again to new cia
officers never turned down a meeting
even with the shadiest character
he earned a law degree left the state
department in 1926 and joined sullivan
and cromwell one of the most powerful
law firms in the world
and by 1930 allen was having numerous
extramarital affairs with his which his
wife clover of course didn't much
appreciate
in the months before pearl harbor dulles
had picked up rumors that donovan
had
been made chief of some nefarious spy
group with secret funds the white house
controlled he knew donovan he liked
beating him on the tennis court but he
decided to keep his distance from
donovan's group to see what else might
be open if the united states joined the
war
after pearl harbor dulles decided to
join the oss
already wealthy from his law practice he
agreed to take no government salary
while he served in the spy agency
his first job was organizing a major
intelligence outpost in new york city to
hatch opera covert operations against
germany
it turned out new york was actually a
good spot
for recruiting foreign spies back then
the city was filled with immigrants
deposed royalty european expats many of
them uh pretty shady characters dreaming
up schemes in their manhattan salons
for underground
revolts in the nazi occupied countries
donovan and dulles weren't particularly
bothered that the a lot of these
would-be emigre spies turned out to be a
waste of their time
new york became a laboratory for dulles
experiments in intelligence gathering
so for example he organized a project to
counterfeit enemy currency
he bought clothes from european refugees
as men interviewed so oss agents
infiltrating enemy territory could wear
the garments to blend in
he even started a secret unit to tap
into the records
that american insurance companies held
on their axis business clients before
the war
now why would he be interested in
insurance files
well
those files often contain the blueprints
of the buildings being insured
allied air forces found those blueprints
particularly useful when they were
trying to figure out how to bomb the
structures
in november 1942 just after the allies
invasion of north africa the torch
invasion dulles slipped into switzerland
with orders from donovan to penetrate
nazi germany
in bern he set up what amounted to a
mini cia
running espionage operations funding
guerrilla missions in occupied france
and italy and inundating washington with
uh foreign policy advice most of it
unsolicited they weren't really
interested in it for his staff dulles
recruited a handful of americans living
in switzerland one of them was mary
bancroft
an american socialite who eventually
became his mistress there
he had scores of informants on his
payroll
many of them turned out to be
professional snitches who often passed
the same secrets to the germans in the
morning the british in the afternoon and
to dulles uh in the evening
but dulles met him all
he didn't want to repeat the mistake he
made in world war one with vladimir
lenin and he had some prized sources he
recruited for example fritz colby a
short bald german foreign office uh
diplomat with big ears and beady eyes
who delivered some 1 000
secret nazi political military and
intelligence cables to dulles
colby uh first had to have a dot or had
the documents strapped around his leg
when he sneaked into switzerland dulles
eventually gave him a miniature camera
so he could photograph the material and
hide the film in a watch case
another valuable source was hans baron
gascivious a very stern obvious major
who had come to detest hitler
on his on his visits to uh burn gasifis
would brief dulles on the dissidents
remaining in germany who were laying
plans to assassinate adolf hitler and
what became known as the valkyrie plot
that failed on july 20th 1944. remember
tom cruise did a movie on on valkyrie
dulles gave gasivius who was a hulk of a
man over six feet tall the code name
tiny
now let's turn to bill casey
his birth in 1913 set a family record
that his mother could have done without
he arrived weighing a staggering 14
pounds
i know everybody's got oh right
the son of a new york tammany hall
bureaucrat casey was a bright child but
he drove not the nuns at catholic
churches at the catholic uh schools uh
nuts because he seemed determined to
educate himself as he saw fit
he went to fordham university he was the
first in his family to go to college
then he went to catholic university of
america in washington to be a social
worker
he quickly became disenchanted with
social work
after serving in the new york social
work department
for about six months
he thought
welfare money was being wasted and
roosevelt was a bleeding heart liberal
casey earned a law degree going to night
school and by the time hitler invaded
poland he was working as an analyst for
the research institute of america which
was a think tank in new york and
washington that advised businesses on
how to land government contracts uh in
roosevelt's new deal
after the united states entered the war
casey who soon was married with a baby
girl wanted in on the action
he talked the navy into making him a
lieutenant junior grade
it took some convincing however
the navy at first didn't think he was
officer material but they ended up
finding a place for him uh in the ship
buying program
board though with pushing paper for the
navy casey noted that notice that a
number of wealthy young men were signing
on with the secret organization that
donovan
had set up
he managed to wangle an interview with
donovan's recruiters but they also
weren't particularly impressed with this
office officer who didn't seem to have
much military bearing but they hired him
and they quickly discovered that casey
was a wizard administration and from his
research institute of america days he
could analyze big chunks of information
and write clear intelligence reports
so they packed him off to the oss's very
important london station at grosvenor
square to manage the flow of paperwork
there
in short order casey had his hand in
every major operation the station was
running he was like a human tornado as
one officer there said of him you could
not not pay attention to bill casey
donovan soon was impressed with his 31
year old navy lieutenant and in december
1944
he made casey his chief of secret
intelligence for europe
and ordered him to infiltrate oss agents
uh ended nuts into the third reich
that was a dawning mission
even though it was losing the war by
this time nazi germany was still one of
the world's most tightly run police
states
the average german citizen
had up to 18 different basic identity
documents that the an oss unit codenamed
bach
had to forge so casey who eventually had
330 people working for him
had to scramble
in the last five months of the war
he managed to parachute more than 150
agents into germany to radio back
intelligence for the advancing allied
armies
his spies often had to improvise on the
fly
for example a two-man team code named
chauffeur enlisted the help of two
french women
working in a forced to work in a
bavarian brothel
the women would entice military secrets
between the sheets from their vermont
customers while one of the oss agents
hid in the closet with a flashlight
taking notes
colby our next subject
he was born in 1920 uh he was he was an
army brat
his father who rose to the rank of of
colonel was something of a curmudgeon
not a particularly pleasant guy to be
around colby spent his early years
moving from one duty station to another
which was an education in itself he
wanted to follow into his father's
footsteps and be an army officer but he
graduated from
high school ahead of schedule at the age
of 16
his yearbook had nicknamed him the brain
and he was too young to enter west point
so he went to princeton like dulles did
and was eventually commissioned an rotc
uh second lieutenant in august 1941
after he turned 21.
bill colby liked to quote
napoleon's standing order for his troops
marched to the sound of the guns
but after pearl harbor it seemed to kobe
as if he was marching in the opposite
direction farther and farther away from
the sound of those guns
he was put in the artillery branch and
stuck at desolate fort sill oklahoma
teaching students how to fire howitzers
one day he spotted a notice on a
bulletin board that said the army wanted
volunteers for a paratroopers in an
airborne artillery unit colby applied
but he worried that his poor eyesight he
wore glasses might disqualify him so he
memorized the eye chart when the doctor
wasn't in the room
of course the doctor caught him
buddy figured colby's eyes were probably
good enough to see the ground when he
parachuted to it so he passed him
bad luck struck once more
on his second jump at fort benning
georgia where he was training to be a
paratrooper he broke his right ankle
by the time it healed and he finished
what remained of his airborne training
he was stuck in a replacement pool at
camp mccall north carolina desperate to
get to the sound of those guns
in mid-october 1943 he spotted another
notice tact to another bulletin board
this one from some strange organization
he never heard of called the oss which
said that if you were a paratrooper and
you spoke french and kobe spoke french
and you were looking for adventure call
this number
so he called
uh and at the end of by the end of the
month he was at the country
congressional country club just outside
of washington that the sea that the oss
had taken over to train spies and
saboteurs
the secret operation he was training for
which was code named jedberg had had
been put together by the british to drop
three-man commando teams into france
just after d-day to organize resistance
attacks against the nazis
from the congressional country club
colby and the other oss recruits were
packed off for more guerrilla training
at a remote camp in maryland's catoctin
mountains near fdr's presidential
retreat which is now called camp david
their next stop was peterborough just
north of london
uh and a country estate called milton
hall where the british contr continued
to train them
in what became a multinational force
mainly of british french and american
officers
this was even more
rigorous uh guerrilla training for him
and there was somewhat of a culture
clash between the american and the
british commandos for example colby and
the other americans had to learn the
british way of parachuting
british commandos jumped out of planes
at altitudes as low as 500 feet
and their parachutes did not come with a
spare in case the first one didn't work
at that low altitude
you really didn't have time to deploy a
spare anyway
the instructors uh told them that if
their chute didn't open to bring it back
and we'll give you a new one
of course the americans didn't find that
joke particularly funny
finally in august 1944 colby's three-man
team dropped into the burgundy region
southeast of paris to organize french
resistance attacks as patton's third
army approached
the the secret war they fought was
complicated
colby's team had to deal with an
assortment of resistance factions that
were poorly trained and equipped
where each faction seemed to have a
private political agenda and they they
often squabbled among themselves as much
as they fought the nazis
and kobe didn't know it at the time
but one of the top resistance leaders he
was working with a man named roger barde
was secretly collaborating with the
germans
the ab verse top spy catcher in french a
guy named hugo bleisher had recruited
bar day to betray his country
after the third army passed through
burgundy and kobe's jedburg assignment
ended he next led a norwegian american
commando team that parachuted into
frigid norway in march 1945.
their mission which was code name repay
after a local bird that changed colors
with the season
was to help keep some three hundred
thousand german occupiers bottled up in
norway so they couldn't be transferred
back to uh germany to fight the allied
advance
this was a tough mission
colby's men ended up fighting norway's
brutal winter weather as much as they
did the germans
half of his 30-man team never made it to
norway because the planes carrying them
couldn't find the drop zone in the snow
or they crashed
colby's commandos did manage to blow up
a bridge and destroy a track a section
of track on the nordland rail line which
was carrying german troops north to
south
but the raids were very risky and the
skiing was absolutely exhausting colby's
team nicknamed one of the mountains they
had to ski over to escape a nazi patrol
benzedrine hill because practically all
of them had to pop the stimulus for the
artificial energy to get to its peak
finally richard helms
he was born barely two weeks after casey
in 1913 but any similarity between the
two boys stopped there
helms's grand grandfather gates megara
was a famous international banker his
father was an alcoa executive
who along with his mother suffered bouts
of depression
the family lived abroad where helms
attended the pricey les rosay school in
switzerland and later the real gymnasium
in freiburg germany
it was a cosmopolitan education that
helms later thought was ideal for a spy
back home he became a big man on campus
at williams college one of the little
ivies with a phi beta kappa key and
harvard law school opened to him if he
wanted it
colby instead chose uh journalism he
hoped to publish a newspaper one day he
signed on with the united press and by
1935
became one of the news agencies
correspondents in berlin where adolf
hitler was wildly popular
his prized assignment came in september
1936
when he covered the annual nazi party
congress in nuremberg
after the rally hitler invited helms and
a half dozen other foreign
correspondents to a lunch at nuremberg
castle
helms was surprised how unremarkable the
fuhrer looked to him
his eyes everyone claimed were hypnotic
were actually a dull slate
blue protruding somewhat from his head
and helms thought they were quite
ordinary
his pasty white face was tinged slightly
pink
gold filled his teeth
and when he talked to the reporters his
knees rocked back and forth which he
helms thought was kind of odd but it was
clear to helms after his uh luncheon
conversation uh with hitler that the
dictator was intent on going to war
after uh pearl harbor helms joined the
navy and was perfectly happy in the
services new york office plotting
merchant ship movements to avoid german
uh u-boat packs when out of the blue the
oss summoned him to its washington
headquarters in august 1943.
donovan's agency had sent a request to
the navy for an officer who spoke french
and german who had lived overseas and
who worked as a reporter an ibm computer
in the navy's personnel office spit out
helms's name the next thing helms knew
he was in a farmhouse in the countryside
north of baltimore for two weeks of spy
training
he learned how to build a cover story to
hide his identity how to pick locks in
burglarized offices how to blackmail
foreign officials for secrets how to
evade shadowing by a gestapo agent how
to fight dirty with knives or pistols or
the jagged edge of a whiskey bottle in a
bar
toward the end of his second week
of training
as a field exercise helms was sent out
with just 18 dollars in his pocket to
try to talk his way into a pittsburgh
steel plant and abscond with documents
on the types of war goods it
manufactured the oss called these
training exercise schemes
his palms sweating and his stomach all
knotted up
helms managed to get his get himself
into the plant he scooped up handfuls of
papers on unattended desks and he
slipped past and in a tent of guards
now
two weeks uh wasn't enough to make helms
a proficient spy if he was actually
going out in the field he'd uh he would
have gotten much more training
but it was enough for a staff job in the
oss washington washington headquarters
on navy hill where he first served in a
planning group dreaming opera up
operations for oss stations abroad and
then uh coordinated intelligence
gathering on the germans
he also had some other odd jobs too
donovan brought charles de gaulle's
intelligence chief who was this unsavory
french colonel
to the united states for what amounted
to a junk junket to butter him up
because he spoke french and he had been
a newspaper man helms was assigned to
the escort team for the colonel
uh the colonel and his aides with the
very important mission of keeping the
frenchman's visit out of american
newspapers
for three weeks the military plane flew
the frenchman helms and the other
escorts around the united states to see
the sites
so they had an expensive night out at
antoine's restaurant in new orleans in
hollywood studio executives arranged for
high-priced call girls to entertain the
colonel and his aides in their hotel
rooms
fortunately for helms nothing ever got
in the newspapers about this
he finally made it to london in january
1945. he roomed with casey who lived
like a slob
and he worked for him keeping an eye on
the joe handlers
os spies the oss sent out were called
joes and the oss hand an oss handler was
assigned to watch over them until they
boarded the plane uh and headed over
anime territory and parachuted out helms
would drive out to harrington field
north of london with the joes and their
handlers
watch the planes take off with the spies
then he'd wait at the airport for the
pilot to return to report back to him
that the drop had been successful
after germany surrendered helms and
dulles moved into war-torn berlin to set
up a spy stage spy station
it's hard for us to imagine today just
how devastated how chaotic and how
violent europe was
just after uh germany's surrender berlin
was like the wild west when helms
arrived
millions of homeless and starving souls
filled the city
billions of flies buzzed over thousands
of rotting corpses in the rubble
criminal gangs roamed
the streets many of them made up of
young orphans and soviet spies infested
the western sectors
the americans the british and the french
occupied
helms and the other station's officers
hunted for war criminals tracked down uh
artwork the nazis had stolen helped
round up german scientists in operation
code name paperclip and even located a
nurse from the furore bunker uh near the
chant right chancellory who detailed for
them hitler's final days before his
suicide
the targets of helm spying soon switched
from the remnants of nazi germany to the
soviets who occupied
east berlin
and under highly classified orders from
donovan helms and the other operatives
in the berlin station also spied on the
british and the french in their uh
sectors as well donovan assumed the
british and the french were spying on
the americans so he wanted to return the
favor
helms dulles colby and casey all
returned home from world war ii not
emotionally drained or scarred from what
they experience you don't find any ptsd
among these four men
instead they return to europe rather
invigorated from their fight against
nazism and ready for the next battle
which was against communism world war ii
had a huge impact on their lives dulles
ran the cia much as he did his oss
station in bern
the oss taught helms how to be a spy and
after the war he decided that his
intelligence collection was his calling
and not newspaper publishing
colby who wore a floppy fatigue hat from
the war when he tended his garden got a
law degree but quickly grew bored with
being a lawyer
he joined the cia to fight communists as
he had
the nazis
when casey became cia director he hung
two
pictures in his office
at cia headquarters at langley ronald
reagan's and a photo of wild bill
donovan his mentor
so let me end it uh there we can talk
about you know if you got any questions
uh we can talk about these four men
anything else they did during the war
their legacy or anything else you got on
your mind
yes
all these men fought in the european
theater
and obviously the oss had operations in
the pacific as well
yeah uh and the question uh is uh
this story is about their secret war in
the european theater
uh what kind of operations did the oss
have in the pacific the short answer
actually is not much
uh
douglas macarthur
didn't think much of donovan's
organization and only allowed a handful
of people in and he was
commander of the southwest pacific
forces commander of the north uh west
pacific forces admiral chester nimitz
didn't see any use for a bunch of spies
and propagandists in what was naturally
a naval war so donovan ended up having
most of his operations in china
and also the burma theater launching
attacks uh against the japanese
occupiers there in china though it was
another case where it took him a long
time to get in the war because he spent
a lot of time spying on chiang
kai-shek's uh
opera uh spies there who spied on his uh
men who were in there too in fact
donovan at one point set up a phony
newspaper in china
and had newspapermen posing uh as spies
to collect intelligence and what chang
was doing
yeah one very ethical thing to do uh
yeah when dallas was in bern
would he not have uh had to keep this
operation a secret even from the swiss
government
uh the question is when dulles was in
bern did he have to keep his c operation
secret from the swiss government the
answer is no
not only did he not really keep it
secret from the swiss government he
didn't keep a secret from the germans or
anybody else
and the reason was largely practical
okay when dulles got into
burn in november 1942 he didn't have
three years to set up a you know an
undercover clandestine spy operation and
infiltrate uh you know agents into
germany or start collecting information
he had hit the floor running
so
both he and donovan decided that
the germans are probably going to find
out what you're doing anyway so he
practically hung a shingle out of his
apartment at harrangassa 23
that says you know
snitches and informants are welcome
here we did now as a result of that he
got a lot of uh uh
obvere and gestapo agents trying to
infiltrate his operation the soviet
intelligence service uh penetrated him
too
fortunately
uh the obver the germans
they knew he was some type of special
representative from fdr and the reason
they knew it because they read it in the
paper
dulles leaked a story that he had come
there as a special representative of fdr
so i didn't take my spy work but
they assumed he was just there
collecting uh economic secrets
and
really the germans assumed anybody in
any type of american diplomatic mission
was a spy didn't matter who they were so
they treated them all as that so the
result is that yeah it was penetrated
but it didn't really produce that much
tidbit
okay i was born in berlin in
1938 fell at austin and i remember as a
child in 1945
or 46 going to the zoo and the american
soldiers were feeding the animal
cigarettes
yeah
the question was i occupied berlin
at the zoo the tear garden
right the tear garden that uh american
soldiers were feeding the animal
cigarettes cigarettes this is probably
what remained of the animals there
because because of the heavy bombing by
soviet artillery in american bombs a lot
of the animals were
fled uh the tear garden literally on
fire
uh i mean it was really horrific so
there wasn't much left there to smoke
but yeah
it was
occupation troops uh it kind of you know
there were problems on all sides there
uh
you know there was a high
venereal disease rate among american
soldiers uh in berlin there was a big
problem with the black marketing uh and
allied forces there dulles had a big
problem in his own oss station there
with some oss officers uh making a
killing on swiss watches they were
sneaking into the country and reselling
an inflated prices in fact he had to
clean out uh some of the people in this
station
a lot what turned out a lot of cases
where there was uh gis that were
committing crimes or anything were
actually
very often nkgb officers in gi suits
were committing the crimes to cast a bad
light on the american occupiers but
there was still a problem with it the
russians dealt with their problem
basically shooting anybody that was
gonna that got too far out of hand
but it was it was really a chaotic
experience i mean the war did not end on
may 8th 1945. i mean the killing did not
end and then you had millions and
millions of displaced displaced people
moving around europe uh the place was
still violent there was still a lot of
death and it was still a lot of chaos in
berlin
yeah
let's get along with eisenhower
the question is did dulles get along
with eisenhower
yeah he did actually uh donovan got
along with eisenhower too
uh and donovan didn't get along with a
lot of american generals and admirals um
he because he tended to make end runs
around him to get what he wanted which
didn't make him too popular
so
eisenhower saw a lot of value in what
dulles was producing in switzerland
keep in mind switzerland was really the
allies or the american
uh their portal to germany uh this was i
mean
it was such a tightly controlled police
state that was difficult to get agents
in you had to look at germany through uh
switzerland and dulles you know came up
with some very significant finds like
fritz colby even though the pentagon at
first thought he was uh you know a
double agent so did the british too
uh
but uh and yeah i i appreciated what
they were doing yeah
how did dulles get along with his
brother john foster
question is how did dulles get along
with his brother john foster dulles
foster was secretary of state the
eisenhower administration he was also a
senior partner in sullivan and cromwell
the international law firm and he
recruited dulles to come to the uh law
firm
in the family
foster was always kind of the number one
the leader of the kids of the siblings
and dulles looked up to him
so when uh
and and
dulles uh became eisenhower's cia
director with a lot of help from uh
foster who was uh the uh secretary of
state
uh dulles
uh deferred to foster in the eisenhower
administration
uh he didn't overtly try to make uh make
foreign policy but he saw himself as a
you know a foreign policy instrument uh
in the eisenhower administration and in
fact there were a lot of people that
thought dulles should have been uh
secretary of state because foster was
you know a real dour
kind of you know moroes type of guy not
really that much fun to be around and
dulles was you know a conversationalist
very you know smooth and everything and
so people tended uh to like him uh even
when he was asking him to do a lot of
dirty things
uh
so
you know you know it's like any any uh
brothers relationship but it made him
very very powerful uh in the eisenhower
administration to have these two
brothers controlling all the national
security levers over and covert
yeah found your story of tiny very very
interesting do you know if he survived
the war uh yeah this is uh tiny uh hans
baron gosivius who was an abver major
who uh
was actually part of a group of senior
abver officers under uh the their
director of the ober admiral wilhelm
kenaras who
also hated hitler and uh secretly
encouraged of the dissident movement
that led to the valkyrie plot
uh tiny
hans baron gosivius
was there in berlin when the plot was
unfolding that day and failed i'm not
sure which one he was in the tom cruise
film but he was one of the guys there
he managed to escape though
uh he managed to get out uh before they
were they rounded up everybody else and
just executed them right on the spot or
you know or scooped them up and tortured
them and executed them later
gazebos uh escaped into berlin roamed
all over berlin for months uh it was
hard for him to hide out because he was
so tall he couldn't walk around
on sidewalks eventually
dulles
managed to get
the london station to fabricate to forge
the identity talk documents gasifis
would need to get out of
germany and into switzerland and they
had an agent slip those identity
documents to gasivius including you know
gestapo badge
you know passports everything and he was
able to climb aboard a train
actually with a senior gestapo
delegation on it he was hiding in plain
sight and make his way to
uh to burn switzerland where he finally
hooked up with dulles completely
emotionally exhausted his hair had
turned completely white it just
destroyed him mentally but then he
worked for dulles afterwards
yeah to what degree did uh kennedy's
reliance and interaction with the cia
change after the bay of pigs the
question is uh what uh was kennedy's how
did kennedy's interaction or reliance on
the sc cia change after the bay of pigs
there's a story circular that circulated
around and it's been reported in other
books that after the bay of pigs uh
kennedy wanted to break up the cia into
a million pieces
uh
and he fired dulles
eventually over it
and i mean he he obviously treated
intelligence and the military too
because the military talked him into it
as well
with a very jaundiced eye afterwards uh
but he was uh he he took the bullet
he didn't you know he didn't publicly
blame dulles i mean he did he there was
like a year interval before he fired him
uh
and uh you know it's interesting you
remember in the famous kennedy press
conference where he's admitting that you
know the bay of pigs thing and he talked
about success having uh
you know 100 fathers
and failure being an orphan you know
where he got that line
uh it was from a manuscript count siano
who was a foreign minister of italy who
was eventually executed by mussolini his
wife sneaked out and dulles helped get
it published eventually in american
newspapers and there was a little line
in there that siano uh uh said that
particular quote i don't think kennedy
ever knew where where the world it came
from i don't know how he even heard it
but uh
saying
a little factoid there
yeah this might not be in your
research but i was wondering if any of
these gentlemen were
um
involved or aware of the enigma project
that was going on breaking of the german
code and that they have any role in it
or was it shared later on good question
uh the question is were any of these
four subjects
involved in ultra the this was the uh
program uh the british program that
broke uh the german uh military code
uh
it was kind of an interesting
relationship that not only the uh the
senior people in the oss and donovan had
with the uh with the british the british
gave donovan access to the raw files of
ultra
which were very very helpful helpful to
him particularly in building up his
counter-espionage service ironically
general george marshall the chief of
staff of the army would not give
donovan access to the magic
code breaking that those uh that raw
take this was the code breaking
capability of japanese diplomatic
and military cables uh marshall worried
that donovan's men would couldn't keep a
secret and it would leak out
so donovan in effect had a more a closer
relationship with the british uh
intelligence service than he did with
his own government uh during the war
the ultra was particularly helpful uh
uh not necessarily directly for dulles
but for the people who were evaluating
the intelligence dollar dulles was
producing and sending to washington
initially in the uh
first
uh months of setting up the station he
had a batting average uh on the
intelligency setup there was a lot of he
passed along rumors and things that just
weren't true and everything and at one
point uh donovan uh one of the senior
aides sent him a very pointed cable that
said that the military is discounting
100 percent everything you're sending us
well as intelligence eventually approved
particularly with fritz colby you
mentioned he was the foreign office a
diplomat that brought in you know the
real you know the real good stuff
what they would do was look at the
uh the ultra take what they were getting
on ultra and compare it to what colby
was telling them
that was happening either in the foreign
office or the military and they saw it
matched up and it was until about six
seven months of colby supplying those
intelligence that when they were
cross-checking with ultra that they
finally determined that you know colby
wasn't a plant he wasn't feeding them
chicken feed everybody know what chicken
feed that's the intelligence term of you
know useless information you feed the
enemy to ingratiate yourself with them
well they determined that kobe was the
real thing
uh took the british a little bit longer
to
agree agree to that but that's where
altra was helpful for him
yeah you mentioned i believe that kobe
was at camp mccall yeah had german pows
arrived there while he was there uh good
question the question was uh camp mccall
north carolina was uh where german pows
there when colby was
i don't know when they got there he was
there in
august september
going into early october 1943.
i he never mentioned any of any of that
in
his uh
you know memoirs and i never really
found anything on it uh he didn't
particularly like camp mccall because he
was stuck there in a replacement pool
and there were a lot of other people
heading over to
germany in
airborne artillery units which turned
out to be he thought a ridiculous idea
you know
because you got when you drop a howitzer
out of a plane they had to drop them in
nine different parts out of the plane
because they're too heavy at one well
when it landed invariably they couldn't
find all nine parts
to put the darn thing back together
again
so kobe didn't see much hope for
airborne artillery but and so he spent
most of his time there trying to figure
out how to get out of there i doubt if
he even noticed you know that many folks
there i'm not sure when the when the
german pows got there some of the pows
fixed peaches on my farm did they really
cut my hair how about that
how about that that's interesting yeah
did dulles ever run across kim philby in
world war ii uh the question is did
dulles ever run across kim philby in
world war ii no he didn't but kim philby
entered into
uh the dulles story uh
that's
at a very critical point
and what it was was toward as the war
was getting near its end
dulles was conducting secret
negotiations with an ss
obergruppenfuhrer
a general uh in in northern italy for
the surrender of
the northern
uh
northern german or the forces german
forces in northern italy this was in
advance of the uh uh
the overall surrender of allied troops
he'd been working on it for a long time
it was very torturous diplomatic uh
negotiations that he was doing in
complete secrecy
uh uh the americans code named the
uh the operation sunrise the british uh
code name it code named it crossword
because dulles i mean because uh
churchill thought it was just a
impenetrable crossword puzzle how they
were ever going to come to this
the where fit colby fits into the
picture i mean where philby fixin fits
into the picture was
the russians were outraged when they
started picking up word about these
secret negotiations the sunrise talk
between uh dulles's station and the uh
and the germans occupying northern italy
in fact stalin and roosevelt exchanged
some of the most hostile mean-spirited
letters there the two guys ever did uh
during the war over the sunrise talks
that uh the russians thought that uh you
know dulles they were negotiating a
secret surrender so those that
german forces in northern italy would
march on uh russia
which wasn't really the case and the
russians wanted to come in there
themselves
well the russians
kobe uh kept his uh sunrise operation
very very secret even kept a secret from
the from the british for a while
but the russians turned out were able to
learn about sunrise through kim philby
who was feeding him a lot of the
information out of london uh on what was
going on uh i'm sure dulles of course he
didn't realize this until long after the
war you know
what that kind of betrayal entailed
so
yeah can you tell us anything about the
dallas brothers involvement in the
overthrow of the duly elected leader of
iran in the early 50s
uh the question is the dulles brothers
involvement in the overthrow of the duly
elected leader in iran in the early 50s
yes they were involved not only that
they were involved in the uh overthrow
of the president of guatemala too
around that time also both of which
in the guatemala case ushered in decades
of brutal military rule in that poor
country and of course in iran ushered in
the shah of iran which after that came
the ayatollah so i mean they were
considered within the agency highly
successful operations that had grave
historical ramifications now
this wasn't a rogue operation by dulles
and uh the dulles brothers eisenhower uh
was behind it and fully approved it i
mean you know you talk about the
assassination plotting of lumumba and
and some of the other ones castro and
whatever with the cia tried uh never
really accomplished uh
these were things that eisenhower was
fixated on too you know he was giving
giving the green light on it you know
dulles had a habit of uh testing the
edge of the envelope on his orders you
know and he might trip over a little bit
uh but he was you know you know he was
wildly popular in the in the 50s i mean
his cover was on time magazine
uh you know as america's super spy i had
read that the dulles brothers were
planning
that overthrow even before eisenhower
was sworn in once they found out he was
elected they figured that they would get
their way i don't know if you
write anything about that i don't know
about foster i could see
alan because he was actually a deputy
director at the cia during the truman
administration under uh general bedell
smith who had been eisenhower's uh chief
of staff
so uh he may have i don't know whether
foster had i'm just getting the the
throat cut sign over there i think we
got time for one other question or right
about the vietnam war colby was approved
the phoenix program yeah
the question
the question is uh during the vietnam
war and kobe's involvement in the
phoenix program the phoenix program
was a broad-based
program
linked with cords and other pacification
programs in vietnam
that
its intent
was to build up
hamlets and villages and weed out
viet cong uh in south vietnam it ended
up with about 20 000 people killed in it
colby defended phoenix and said most of
those uh deaths are almost all were
combat casualties well it turned out an
awful lot of the phoenix deaths were
assassinations and tortures and that a
lot of the operators that worked with
phoenix under the cia even though colby
sent out memos because he was involved
in it saying you know we don't condone
extrajudicial punishment or whatever
bureaucracies they use
a lot of
a lot of that was still going on so
colby always defended his uh
his role in vietnam he was as proud of
that as his
work in the oss i mean he thought
that it was a travesty that the dmr uh
brothers were overthrown in vietnam um
and that that we could have won the war
uh diamond
and his family had still been in power
which um probably nothing could have
been further from the truth
so well thank you very much i appreciate
uh you've been a good audience
thank you so much for coming tonight he
will sign books at the table and we have
them for sale at the counter thank you
[Music]
underwater